SEAN WILL BE BACK ON MONDAY.
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" IS UP NOW.
>>♪.
>> Laura: I AM LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS THE "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM A ROCKING WASHINGTON.
WE WILL GET RIGHT INTO IT.
A TALE OF TWO FUTURES.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
YOU JUST WITNESSED TWO WEEKS,
TWO PARTY’S CONVENTIONS AND TWO
VISIONS FOR AMERICA.
ALL WEEKLONG AMERICA SAW
A REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT WAS
HOPEFUL AND OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE
FUTURE CAPPED OFF BY A SOARING
ADDRESS AT ANY RATE PRESIDENT
LAST NIGHT.
>> TOGETHER WE WILL WRITE THE
NEXT CHAPTER OF THE GREAT
AMERICAN STORY.
OVER THE NEXT 4 YEARS, WE WILL
MAKE AMERICA INTO THE
MANUFACTURING SUPER POWER OF THE
WORLD.
THE UNITED STATES WILL BE THE
FIRST NATION TO PLANT ITS
BEAUTIFUL FLAG ON MARS.
WE WILL REKINDLE NEW FAITH IN
OUR VALUES, NEW PRIDE IN OUR
HISTORY, AND A NEW SPIRIT OF
UNITY THAT CAN ONLY BE REALIZED
THROUGH LOVE FOR OUR GREAT
COUNTRY.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Laura: MUCH TO THE DISMAY OF
THE MEDIA HALL MONITORS, OUR
ENERGIZER BUNNY TRAVELED TO NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
THE CONTRAST BETWEEN HIM AND
BIDEN IS STARK.
>> WE ARE IN THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTION IN OUR HISTORY.
LAST NIGHT IT WAS MY GREAT HONOR
TO ACCEPT THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
WEEK  --
>> WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
I BELIEVE I HAVE THE HONOR OF
RUNNING AGAINST THE WORST
CANDIDATE EVER PUT UP BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I BELIEVE HE IS THE WORST
CANDIDATE, THE SLOWEST
CANDIDATE, AND I MEAN IN
PRIME-TIME HE WAS THE SLOWEST
CANDIDATE, WHICH WAS A LONG TIME
AGO.
PRIME-TIME.
>> Laura: IN TRUMP’S AMERICA WE
BELIEVE THE BEST IS YET TO COME.
THIS WAS SAID OVER AND OVER BY
SPEAKERS AT THE RNC.
IT WASN’T JUST RHETORIC.
THEY REALLY MEAN IT.
AND THAT BUOYANT SUNNY OUTLOOK
WAS NOT FROM CELEBRITIES LIVING
BEHIND WALLS AND HAVE HANDLERS,
BUT FROM EVERY DAY AMERICANS WHO
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN THE FOCUS OF
TRUMP’S AGENDA FOR AMERICA.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP’S ECONOMIC
BOON HELPED FARMERS.
>> WHEN HE SEES SOMETHING IS NOT
RIGHT, HE IS FEARLESS IN FIXING.
>> I WAS ONCE TOLD THE ONLY WAY
I WOULD BE REUNITED WITH MY
FAMILY WOULD BE AS A CORPSE.
WITH THE GRACE OF GOD AND THE
COMPASSION OF DONALD TRUMP
DONALD TRUMP, I STAND BEFORE YOU
TONIGHT AND I AM NOT A GHOST.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT DIDN’T
RUN AWAY FROM COVID.
HEAVE RAN TO -- HE RAN TOWARD
THE ISSUE AND TALKED ABOUT HIS
OWN FRIENDS WHO HAVE PASSED AWAY
BECAUSE OF THE DISEASE AND THE
N O UP AND GET
BACK TO SCHOOL AND PURSUE OUR
AMERICAN DREAMS.
WE HAVE TO.
ON THE OTHER HAND, AT THEIR
CONVENTION, THE DEMOCRATS
PAINTED DEPRESSING AND GLOOMY
PORTRAIT OF AMERICAN LIFE.
DID YOU KNOW THAT YOU LIVE IN
A HORRIBLE, ROTTEN, AWFUL
COUNTRY?
>> WE CALL OUT THE SINCE OF THIS
NATION.
SLAVERY AND RACISM.
>> IT’S THE EFFECT OF STRUCTURAL
RACISM.
THERE IS NO VACCINE FOR RACISM.
>> WILL WE BE THE GENERATION
THAT FINALLY WIPES OUT THE STAIN
OF RACISM FROM OUR NATIONAL
CHARACTER?
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS WERE
TRYING TO CONVINCE YOU THAT POOR
OLD JOE SHOULD BE THE PRESIDENT.
THEY FAILED TO DEAL WITH THE
VIOLENCE IN CITIES ACROSS
AMERICA.
THE PORTLAND RIOTS AND
DESTRUCTION AND LOOTING IN
CHICAGO.
DID THEY THINK PEOPLE WOULD NOT
SEE THE VIDEO ON SOCIAL MEDIA OF
ALL OF THE BURNING?
THE DEMOCRATS MADE A CALCULATED
DECISION NOT TO ADDRESS THE
VIOLENCE AND RIOTS AS LONG AS
THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD HELP
THEM POLITICALLY.
THE MOMENT DON LEMON LET IT SLIP
THAT SOME FOCUS GROUP WAS
SHOWING DEMOCRAT VOTER EROSION
BECAUSE OF THE UNREST.
JOE AND KAMALA HARRIS TRIED TO
TURN THE TITANIC AROUND.
>> WE MUST ALWAYS DEFEND
PEACEFUL PROTESTORS.
WE SHOULD NOT CONFUSE THEM WITH
THOSE LOOTING AND COMMITTING ACT
OF VIOLENCE.
>> BURNING DOWN COMMUNITIES IS
NOT PROTESTS.
IT’S NEEDLESS VIOLENCE THAT
SHUTTERS BUSINESSES.
THAT’S WRONG.
>> Laura: TALK ABOUT DESPERATE
AND DELUSIONAL.
TOO BAD HE AND KAMALA HARRIS
DIDN’T HAVE AN ENTIRE WEEK TO
CONDEMN THE RIOTS.
WAIT, THEY DID.
TRUMP OFFERED ASSISTANCE TO
EVERY GOVERNOR AND EVERY MAYOR
GRABBLING WITH OUT OF CONTROL
VIOLENCE.
HOW DID THEY RESPOND?
>> I WANT TO ASSURE THE
PRESIDENT SEATTLE IS FINE.
>> WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF FEDERAL
TROOPS DESCENDING UPON OUR CITY.
IT’S NOT HELPING THE SITUATION
AT ALL.
THEY ARE NOT WANTED HERE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, BRINGING THOSE
TROOPS TO OUR CITY, THAT WON’T
HAPPEN IN SHOULD GO.
>> WE WILL FIGHT WITH EVERYTHING
WE HAVE.
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS MINIONS ARE
THE ARCHITECTS OF CHAOS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: IT’S TRUMP?
BECAUSE THEY WANTED THE ED THEED
TO GO ON JOE BIDEN CLAIMS.
DID HE ENJOY THESE SCENES LAST
NIGHT AFTER THE FESTIVITIES
ENDED.
>> [SHOUTING].
>> BLACK LIVES MATTER.
>> Laura: I DON’T BELIEVE THAT
POOR OLD JOE LIKES THESE
SEQUENCE.
-- SCENES, BUT HE’S TOO WEAK TO
STOP IT.
I THINK A LOT OF DEMOCRATS ARE
EMBARRASSED ABOUT THE PARTY’S
UNSAVORY ALLIANCES AND
OUTSOURCING AMERICAN JOBS AND
PLACATING CHINA.
THEY WANT MOUNT RUSH MORE TO
COME DOWN?
I DON’T THINK THAT.
BUT IT DOESN’T MATTER.
THEY SHOW JOE BIDEN ONE OF THE
WEAKEST CANDIDATES IN MODERN
HISTORY AS THEIR NOMINEE.
AND AS VICTOR SAID LAST NIGHT
BIDEN IS A PRISONER OF HIS OWN
PARADOX.
HE HAS NO ENERGY SO HE TRIED TO
RIDE THE FAR LEFT TO VICTORY ON
NOVEMBER 3rd.
NOW THAT WAVE PULLED HIM UNDER
AND A RIPTIDE IS DROWNING THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO OFFER THE
VOTERS.
THEY CAN’T SOLVE THE VIOLENCE
PROBLEM AND THEY ARE NOT
EXPECTED TO FIX IT.
>> HOW CAN THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
ASKED TO LEAD OUR COUNTRY WHEN
IT SPENDS SO MUCH TIME TEARING
DOWN OUR COUNTRY?
>> Laura: THEY CAN’T BRING BACK
JOBS WHEN THEIR TRADE POLICIES
LEAD TO MORE OUTSOURCES.
>> JOE BIDEN TOOK DONATION FROM
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS AND THEN
VOTED TO SHIP OUR JOBS TO CHINA.
CHINA WANTS HIM TO WIN.
>> Laura: THE IDEA THAT JOE
BIDEN WILL SOLVE COVID?
OH, PLEASE.
HE SAID HE WILL LOCK US DOWN IF
THE EXPERTS SAY SO.
THAT WILL LEAD TO INCREASED
SUICIDE, ADDICTION AND JOB
LOSSES.
DEMOCRATS’S SOLUTION IS TO HURT
KIDS BY LEAVING HIM OUT OF
SCHOOL AND TAKE AWAY JOYS LIKE
PLAYING FOOTBALL.
THAT WON’T SOLVE COVID.
BUT IT WILL MAKE OUR LIVES
MISERABLE.
ALL DEMOCRATS HAVE LEFT IS TWO
ARGUMENTS.
NUMBER 1, AMERICA IS RACIST AND
NUMBER 2, TRUMP IS BAD.
THE RNC BLEW UP THAT NARRATIVE
SHOWCASING STORIES FROM EVERY
DAY AMERICANS WHOSE LIVES WERE
IMPACTED IN POSITIVE WAYS BY
TRUMP’S AMERICA FIRST POLICIES,
INCLUDING AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN
AND WOMEN.
THIS OUTREACH HAS THE DEMOCRATIC
TICKET FLUM OXED.
WE SAW IN THIS TODAY SHOW
INTERVIEW OF KAMALA HARRIS.
>> THERE SEEMS TO BE A LARGER
NUMBER OF BLACK MEN FRONT AND
CENTER.
IT WOULD SEEM AS IF REPUBLICANS,
PERHAPS, SEE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE
THAT DEMOCRATS DON’T SEE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, EVERY VOTE
NEEDS TO BE EARNED.
JOE AND I BELIEVE THAT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE CONDITION OF
BLACK MEN IN AMERICA, WE KNOW WE
STILL HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
YOUR PARTY HAD DECADES TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM AND YOU FALSELY SAY
REPUBLICANS ARE RACISTS.
TRUMP WAS DELIVERING RESULTS.
DEMOCRATS ONLY KNOW ONE THING,
REVERTING BACK TO THE SAME OLD
STALE NARRATIVE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE THE ONES
TRAPPED IN THE PAST.
IT FEELS LIKE YOU ARE STUCK IN
A STUDENT SIT IN THAT NEVER
ENDS.
LOOK AT WHAT THE VOTERS ARE
DOING TO PEOPLE JUST TRYING TO
LIVE THEIR LIVES.
>> PUT THE MASK ON NOW.
[BLEEP].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> Laura: IT DOESN’T HAVE TO BE
THIS WAY.
THERE IS A NORMAL WORLD OUT
THERE, AND PEOPLE IN RED STATES
ARE BACK TO LIVING IN THAT
WORLD.
SCHOOL, WORK, SPORTS, CHURCH.
FELLOWSHIP.
I AM REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
AMERICA IN 2021 AND 2022.
I THINK THE SILENT MAJORITY IS
STIRRING.
DON’T YOU?
WITHOUT COVID TRUMP WOULD HAVE
WON IN A LANDSLIDE.
EVEN WITH THE VIRUS, REMEMBER
THIS, IT’S EVENTUALLY GOING TO
GO AWAY OR WE WILL HAVE BETTER
TREATMENT.
BUT IT’S NO REASON TO TOSS
AMERICA IN A DUMPSTER AND SET
HER ON FIRE.
THAT’S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING TO THEIR OWN CITIES.
THEY ARE AT RISK OF BEING LEFT
BEHIND FOR DECADE PHYSICAL THEY
DON’T MAKE SERIOUS CHANGES NOW.
THAT’S UP TO THEM BUT THEY WON’T
STOP US FROM LIVING OUR GOD
GIVEN DESTINY IN REACHING FOR
THE STARS.
THEY MIGHT HAVE GIVEN UP ON